A dark take on the Archie comics, CW's Riverdale
helped launch the careers of a number of new
stars when it debuted in early 2017.
It's also provided a new home for some big-name
talent who've largely disappeared from Hollywood.
From the show's central cast of angsty teens
to its supporting 90s heartthrobs and heathens,
these actors have been collectively racking
up credits for a while now, and some of their
former projects just might surprise you.
Here's why the cast of Riverdale looks so
familiar.
KJ Apa
Riverdale's resident ginger pretty boy Archie
Andrews might seem like the all-American type
— but he's actually portrayed by dark-haired,
New Zealand-born KJ Apa.
Pretty crazy, huh?
Apa got his start in his home country on the
soap opera Shortland Street, appearing in
46 of the show's thousands of episodes as
the angsty teen Kane Jenkins.
Apa also briefly appeared in the New Zealand
sci-fi series The Cul De Sac before landing
a part as a young Dennis Quaid in the controversial
film A Dog's Purpose.
Lili Reinhart
Lili Reinhart, who plays Betty, Riverdale's
token ponytailed blonde, got her start in
acting in the drama short For Today in 2010.
Following an appearance on Law and Order:
SVU, she returned to film as the title character
in the horror flick Lilith and the 2012 drama
short The Most Girl Part of You.
2013 was a huge year for her: She starred
in The Kings of Summer, the baseball mystery
Gibsonburg, and the thriller Forever's End.
In 2014, Reinhart snagged a recurring role
on the Fox mid-season comedy Surviving Jack,
which was canceled after one season.
Then came Riverdale in 2017, and the rest
is history.
Cole Sprouse
Child actor Cole Sprouse was probably the
most famous of Riverdale's young actors when
he was cast as Archie's BFF Jughead.
Sprouse said he was drawn to Jughead because
he was so different from his well-known Disney
Channel character, Cody Martin, whom he'd
played for eight years in The Suite Life of
Zack and Cody and its spin-off The Suite Life
on Deck.
Sprouse already had a lot of acting experience
when he signed on to the Suite Life universe.
The Sprouse twins started acting in 1993 when
they were just 1-year-olds in Chuck Lorre's
Grace Under Fire.
The Sprouse twins also appeared in the Adam
Sandler film Big Daddy.
"Kangaroo song!"
"ALRIIIIIIGHT!"
Meanwhile, Cole — without his brother — struck
TV gold when he played Ross' son Ben on iconic
sitcom Friends.
Camila Mendes
Newcomer Camila Mendes was the least experienced
of Riverdale's teens when she signed on to
play the socialite Veronica Lodge — but
she's quickly proven her acting prowess.
Mendes graduated from NYU's Tisch School of
the Arts in May of 2016, just a few months
after she landed the part of Veronica.
Her only other previous acting credit was
in a commercial for IKEA.
Although Mendes might not be recognizable
from her time before the show, she's blown
up since season one kicked off, even nabbing
more than 1 million followers on Twitter and
7 million followers on Instagram.
That's what we call a success story!
Casey Cott
Casey Cott plays Betty's BFF Kevin on Riverdale,
and while he seems right at home on the small
screen, most of Cott's pre-Riverdale experience
came in local theater.
Cott's on-screen acting experience was pretty
limited before Riverdale — he appeared in
an episode of Law and Order: SVU and starred
in the music video for Sabrina Carpenter's
"Why."
Cott must've really wanted a part on Riverdale
when the show came around, auditioning for
Archie and Jughead before landing the role
of Kevin.
Madelaine Petsch
The red-headed Madelaine Petsch was actually
auditioning for a role on an entirely different
series when she landed the now-iconic part
of Cheryl Blossom on Riverdale.
Petsch, who says she caught the performing
bug at the age of three, was meeting with
casting director David Rappaport for The CW
series Legends of Tomorrow when he pinned
her for Cheryl.
Although she was still fairly new to acting
at the time, Petsch had still boasted appearances
in the Nickelodeon series Instant Mom and
the fantasy flick The Curse of Sleeping Beauty.
Plus, she played a key role in a national
Coca-Cola billboard advertising campaign in
the summer of 2014.
Ashleigh Murray
Ashleigh Murray never ceases to steal a scene
— so it's pretty shocking to hear how little
experience the talented actress had before
landing the role of Pussycats bandleader Josie.
Murray's few credits before Riverdale include
bit parts in episodes of The Following and
Younger as well as roles in the shorts Finding
Harmony, Welcome to New York, and Grind.
Success came quickly for Murray after she
landed her role on Riverdale with a leading
role in the Sundance Film Festival breakout
Deidra and Laney Rob a Train in early 2017.
Luke Perry
Former teen hunk Luke Perry already had a
lot of experience on teen shows when he signed
on to appear as Archie's dad Fred on Riverdale,
starring on the wildly popular Beverly Hills,
90210 for nine years.
During his time on 90210, Perry also made
the rounds in film and television, appearing
in the movie version of Buffy the Vampire
Slayer and starring in other flicks like The
Fifth Element and 8 Seconds.
He also made guest appearances on an extensive
list of shows like Will and Grace, What I
Like About You, Leverage, Community, Body
of Proof, Raising Hope, Major Crimes, and
Criminal Minds.
The actor has said he was "skeptical" about
making his return to television when Riverdale
came along, but, luckily, his agent pushed
him to read the script, and — just like
the show's devotees — he was hooked.
Molly Ringwald
After landing a teen heartthrob to play Archie's
father, it makes sense that Riverdale's producers
would seek out another huge star to play his
mother.
Enter Molly Ringwald, a venerable icon since
the 1980s and everybody's first redhead crush.
Ringwald's many — many — film roles during
her "Brat Pack" teen-star days include Sixteen
Candles, The Breakfast Club, and Pretty in
Pink.
Early on in her career, she also appeared
in various TV series like Diff'rent Strokes
and The Facts of Life.
Ringwald's stepped out of the spotlight since
the '80s, but she still pops up on the big
screen every now and then.
She was also a series regular on ABC Family's
The Secret Life of the American Teenager,
and she booked guest appearances on Medium
and Psych along with a lead role in the Canadian
series Raising Expectations.
Mädchen Amick
Playing the Betty's mother, Alice Cooper — no,
not that Alice Cooper — Mädchen Amick is
another one of Riverdale's resident creepy
parents with a pretty impressive acting past.
Most notable is her role as the waitress Shelley
Johnson on David Lynch's supernatural mystery
Twin Peaks, a role that she reprised in the
1992 prequel film Fire Walk With Me and the
cult hit's 2017 reboot Twin Peaks: The Return.
Amick's popped up here and there in a ton
of big-name shows since, from American Horror
Story to Gilmore Girls.
But viewers may also recognize her from her
recurring roles in Central Park West, Freddie,
and Witches of East End.
Marisol Nichols
Marisol Nichols has been conniving and cutthroat
in her role as Veronica's mother Hermione
Lodge, but she's also brought a lot of sensitivity
to the serious part.
This is thanks to Nichols' long-time experience
in the acting business, which kicked off in
1996 with guest appearances on the short-lived
sitcom My Guys and Beverly Hills, 90210.
Like many of her adult Riverdale co-stars,
Nichols was once a teen fixture in well-known
movies like Can't Hardly Wait, Vegas Vacation,
and Scream 2.
She's also appeared on TV in a number of fan-favorite
shows like Charmed, Friends, and Boy Meets
World, before hitting it big on Fox's 24,
playing Special Agent Nadia Yassir.
Mark Consuelos
Cast as Veronica's intense father Hiram Lodge
in Riverdale's second season, Mark Consuelos
started acting in 1995 when he starred in
the soap opera All My Children until 2010.
In fact, that's where he met his wife, TV
host Kelly Ripa!
During that time, he also booked dozens of
other acting gigs, including guest-starring
roles on shows like Friends, American Family,
and Third Watch.
He's also appeared in shows like Ugly Betty,
Law and Order: Special Victims Unit, and American
Horror Story: Asylum.
Talk about a well-rounded CV!
Skeet Ulrich
Another former teen star recruited to play
a Riverdale parent, Skeet Ulrich was so impressive
as Jughead's criminal father FP in season
one that he was bumped up to a series regular
for season two — despite his character's
incarceration that is.
He started off his acting career with small
uncredited roles in Weekend at Bernie's and
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles before breaking
out with a performance in the movie The Craft.
Though horror hounds will likely recognize
him as villain Billy Loomis in 1996's Scream.
During the '90s, he also had roles in Boys,
Ride with the Devil, and As Good as it Gets.
Ulrich stayed in the spotlight in the next
decade as well, appearing on the TV series
Into the West, Miracles, and Jericho, and
later guest starring in CSI: New York and
Law and Order: LA.
Martin Cummins
Actor Martin Cummins, who plays the dead serious
Sheriff Keller, has the experience necessary
for a show where everyone is suspect — he's
held more than 75 credits stretching back
to 1987, after all.
Although Cummins didn't achieve the same kind
of 1990s relevance as some of his co-stars,
he was a vital player in a lot of different
TV shows and movies, ranging from 21 Jump
Street to Highlander to Born to Run.
In the late '90s, Cummins signed on to appear
in sci-fi smash Stargate SG-1.
This move gave him the geek cred to later
show up in Smallville, and Kyle XY, and Bates
Motel.
Lochlyn Munro
OK, so Betty's dad Hal Cooper isn't the most
congenial of Riverdale's grownups.
But the actor who plays him, Lochlyn Munro,
seems like a perfectly nice guy — and a
busy one, with over 200 credits to his name.
Munro hasn't had many parts that stuck around
for long, but he has been a prolific guest
star, appearing on shows like Charmed, Psych,
Bones, Lucifer, and Supernatural.
While he's no stranger to T.V., Munro's probably
more well-known for his many film roles, which
come from a variety of genres, from campy
horror flicks like Freddy vs. Jason to comedies
like Scary Movie and Daddy Day Camp.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!